[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
quack
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it is week nine fellas it's week nine
how y'all doing man y'all doing good
living the dream man couldn't be better
if you guys don't know if you guys don't
know I got Sam Richmond and producer
Ryan
next to me uh Sam we we both was in
Houston last night we both was with
mattress smack the legend who made
sports betting history uh how we feeling
this morning bro
yeah I mean it's it's been a pretty
incredible like last week or two for
this entire BR betting team just being
so close to the mattress Max situation
and it's just just was surreal to see
this man actually win 75 million dollars
and and shut up all the haters and
losers of which there are many out there
uh man that was that was crazy just to
be a part of it was crazy Ryan I know
you saw it on the outside looking in
like what's your take being a fan of a
sports betting fan listen there's no
greater day than when I get to see the
city of Philadelphia lose I mean no no
greater day I mean there's somebody it's
your boy in here saying that you guys
are hungover after party with mattress
Mac last night I was partying just
celebrating a Philly's loss I mean there
was parties left and right so I'm
feeling good
there might be some truth to that but I
don't I don't know we'll we'll see hey
but let's get to the show guys let's get
right to the show six bets we love
the man here Sam Richmond Sam let's get
straight to the point like there's no
reason to talk let's just get straight
to the point 45 seconds it's on the
clock you guys know the deal Sam's gonna
give us six picks Sam you ready
I'm ready let's do it hey let's get
right to it all right we're starting off
hot we're taking the Washington
commanders plus three uh look give
credit to the Vikings six and one it's
impressive I personally think they're
due for a ton of regression uh we can
start the dvoa counter right now this
will be my first mention they are ranked
18th overall in team DVA to put that in
perspective that is one worse than the
two and six Jaguars I just don't think
this is a six in one type quality team
um I really like sort of what heinecke
has brought to the table for the
commanders with his rushing ability adds
a new Dynamic to the offense their
defense has looked really good in the
past few weeks they're getting to the
quarterback they made life a mess for
Aaron Rodgers I can't even imagine what
they're gonna do to Mr Kirk Cousins
Raiders boy so I like Commanders
there it is my man Sam Richmond
off the bat rocking with the commanders
and the points let's bring in producer
Ryan because he is our connection he is
our guy that connects us Sam to the
audience he's in the chat producer Ryan
talk to us what are you seeing what's
going on do they like this first pick
I don't think there's a bigger supporter
of the commies than than Sam I mean it
doesn't really matter who's that
quarterback it's wence it's heinecke
you're all over though no matter what
they cash for me though that's true I
don't think I've lost with them if
they're winning you money it doesn't
matter uh so a lot of people in this
chat like the Vikings to win but I want
to win is jumping in here saying it's
not about winning it's about covering
and they're getting you're getting field
goal value there
uh
we've got a TJ arms saying commanders
plus three and a half is preposterous uh
and then uh Drew sather saying worst bet
of the year I I disagree but yeah that's
what I'm looking for that's what I want
hey Sam if they ain't hating you ain't
doing it right so just know if they
ain't hating you ain't doing it right
producer Ryan let's send you back to the
chat brother appreciate you uh Sam we
got
five more to go one down five more to go
let's put 45 seconds back on the clock
there it is Sam take it away
all right up next we are going with
Colts plus five uh to me this is just
too many points for Mac Jones and how
he's playing right now
um looked really shaky last week even
though we did we were able to catch that
Pat's bet over the Jets but got bailed
out on just one of the worst pick sixes
I've ever seen with a roughing the
passer
um the Pats it was terrible the Pats
don't trust him at all they're going to
be conservative they're going to run the
ball but that actually works really well
in the Colts favor because one of the
few things they do well is stop the run
and I will say this I know they did lose
last week but I did I do think Sam
allenger was an upgrade over Matt Ryan I
think they're they're opening up the
field a little bit more because they can
throw it for the five yards down the
field so I like to cover the points here
hey Sam you're a big Coach Guy huh big
Sam Ellinger guy
I just think I I'm actually just very
anti-matt Ryan I think Matt Ryan was
like the worst quarterback in the league
by far and I think you could put anyone
in there and it would have been an
upgrade
anti-matt Ryan anti-met Ryan is what my
man Sam is we need some of that in the
comments uh Hey two down Sam too down
four more to go
45 seconds back on the clock please
let's get right to it Sam we're just
gonna go we're just gonna go today 45
seconds Love It Go
all right uh next I'm going with bucks
minus three got got a nice little battle
here between two teams that have just
underperformed all year
um but I just think it's a lot more
conceivable as the Bucks bounce back I I
just think the Rams at this point we can
say just aren't a very good team and it
cost me last week when I bet against
them or bet on them against your Niners
but they're just not good they're old
they're very top heavy they're ranked
24th in dvoa there's like they just were
nine weeks in this just isn't a very
good team and yes the Bucks haven't been
very good but their defense is top five
and I just think they have more weapons
right the Rams all they do is have his
cup
um that's all they're using I think the
bucks at least have the weapons they're
often decent and I think their defense
will lead them here there it is
um
I told you about last week brother but
I'm not gonna listen I should have
listened I I don't know it was tough for
me because I was like they're gonna miss
Debo and Christian can't do it all on
himself and then he threw for a
touchdown and it was just an absolute
monster so I take the L there
we lose Greg I think we might have lost
Greg but that's Greg it was a perfect
time for him to gloat about me being
wrong in the Niners and and he left so
that's great
um wow should I just keep rolling Ryan
uh do you want to jump into some chat
real quick yeah because I feel the chat
the people the people have some tastes
yeah the people have some takes uh
catfish 44 saying good pick with the
Colts uh we've got C Garcia saying Colts
win unless zappy comes in is that is
that a concern of yours that Bailey
zappy makes it appearance I don't think
I don't think they're gonna do it
because they won last week like I think
they lost last week I don't know
um but I also don't think zappy is that
great like you know it might be better
than mac but I'm not like terrified of
Bailey's happy that's fair I mean you
could definitely move more than than
Matt Ken uh I'll take I'll take some
heat on a comment here uh that's easy
saying tell producer Ryan what's up with
that Dak pick he graded as an F I posted
last week it hit are y'all gurus or just
people taking bets I'm not a guru I I
have never claimed to be a guru I'm also
very anti-deck so my bias there claimed
to be a guru yes we're just people we're
we're the same we're just making bets
we're all friends in here yes except one
person wins their bets significantly
more than the other does that would be
you uh yes yeah if you enlisted if you
ask me about Dak I'm always gonna say
Fay Dak so it was nothing personal
that's easy it's just that's just that's
just how it goes
um but yeah you want to jump into your
next pick here
Let's Do It
um all right we are going to go with the
Falcons plus three it's kind of crazy I
think if you look to this matchup at the
start of the year you would have thought
this would just be a mismatch of the
highest order and it's just not like not
only the record similar but the
statistical profiles are similar Falcons
20th in dvoa and not that much higher is
is the Chargers at 16th
um but I think the thing I really like
most about this matchup is just it this
is just a good matchup for the Falcons
they want to run the ball their entire
offense is predicated on running the
ball and ball control and that's where
the Chargers really struggle they're
23rd in Rush defuni defense dvoa the
Falcons are getting back Cordero
Patterson which adds another bit of uh
dynamicness is that a word we're gonna
go with it to the offense so three
points at home when they're pretty
similar and it's a good matchup for them
I'm taking it every time uh not entirely
sure dynamicness is a word yeah yeah we
need uh this but this is where I would
go to you and say producer Ryan can you
Google if dynamicness is another word
but Greg kind of abandoned us so we'll
have to do that later we do have the
king back I believe I'm being told the
king is back there he is there he is
Mack I'ma call you back hey I got a
phone call you know I had a business
business caller hat that I could get to
but uh
you know I'm discussing I'm discussing
about that percentage you know uh Mac
wants us actually to head over after
this but hey
Sam I see you got four picks I I see you
got four down two more to go right
let's do it producer Ryan
he got two more to go am I correct yes
he is uh yes I am producer Ryan we're
going to send you away Sam let's get
right to it 45 seconds on the clock
talk to him
well every week I come on the show and
every week
I bet the Seahawks and I say the same
thing every single week about how how
legit they are and how good they are and
then the BET ends up crashing so I'm
going to the exact same thing this week
this Seahawks team is really really good
like it just it is what it is they're
sixth over on DBA they have the number
one offense in dvoa
um Geno Smith has been amazing MVP
candidate
um to me there's just no world where
they should be underdogs against the
Arizona Cardinals who just have been not
good they're ranked 30th over on DBA
just have not been a good team and and
Kingsbury and Tyler I'm just so out on
that group so if you're giving me the
Seahawks with points uh I'm and you're I
didn't even mention your boy Kenneth
Walker Greg um every time
there it is Kenneth Walker III make sure
you say the third Sam all right Sam you
got five five picks
we got one more get straight to a 45
seconds on the clock
let's go
all right I think this is gonna be the
one I now I don't know the comments
might have already just be annihilated
me all week but I do think this is the
one that's gonna get me in the most
trouble but uh we're going with the
bears plus four look I think everyone's
everyone's rushing about the Dolphins I
get it their offense is absolutely
Dynamic they've got so many Playmakers
and let's be face let's face it it's the
bears but I think there are some real
concerns about that Dolphins defense
they get shredded week after week 20th
overall 25th overall and and just
overall defense uh divoa is just it's
just not good
um really a struggle to get to the
quarterback I know I know they traded
for Chubb which I think is going to help
them a lot
um I'm just not sure if I'm buying this
just immediate turnaround overnight and
Justin Fields has sneaky been playing
very very well
um so four points at home uh against a
poverty defense I think the Bears can do
enough I know I'm going over to keep it
close
room to go over just because you you got
kicked out so you weren't able to hear
all my glorious texts earlier so I just
wanted to give you an extra 15 seconds
of my takes hey I appreciate that I
appreciate the extra 15. let's bring in
producer Ryan because what is the chat
talking about Ryan are they liking this
loving this eh not so much talk to us uh
well Etc uh quoting one of I think Sam's
favorite lines from this season which is
uh Geno still ain't right back
they wrote him off and I have not seen
him address a letter back today
Michael Boling saying uh lfg Sam Bears
money line book it uh okay we'll stay
away from the money line we'll just take
we'll take the points uh Bella's saying
you're shot if you think the Bears are
winning he you don't think the Bears are
winning
right uh Anthony Pittman saying uh he
loves home dogs you also a big home dog
guy love it I love it this league is
just so close there's so much parody in
this league if you're giving me a home
dog I'm gonna take it most times and
it's been pretty profitable so we'll
rock with it again here yeah and then uh
Alec Byron saying how is this guy the
betting Guru Sam are you 38 and 23 on
the season something like that oh yeah
I'll have to look up Loretta yeah
give out winners every week every
comment is he sucks so we'll see maybe I
have to go 6-0 to get a positive comment
so that's okay it's got a bowling hey
Sam if they ain't hating if you if they
ain't hating you ain't doing it right so
we know what you do I don't think that
our commenter is getting a percent I
think it's just me you and Ryan hey
that's what I'm saying that's what I'm
saying hey but let's move on guys
because I'm gonna boost the anytime
TouchDown for you guys but I need
everybody to get in the chat and tell me
what they want boosted Ryan can you
please pull up those odds brother let's
do it all right top eight top eight most
bet on uh players at DraftKings we've
got number one
Austin Eckler minus 165. number two
Stefan Diggs minus 110. we we ran Stefan
Diggs a few weeks ago against Pittsburgh
he cashed for us uh Aaron Jones minus
175 as AJ Dylan no longer ceases to
exist in that backfield uh number four
Justin Jefferson plus money Greg what
have we said about Justin Jefferson a
plus money hey every time I'm taking it
every time every single time
uh and then round it out at the bottom
no there's no question round it out at
the bottom uh David Cook minus one um
minus 115 and Tyreek Hill also plus
money today against the Chicago Bears
swiss cheese defense so those are my
best bet
okay yes sir uh you are you are our
connection to the chat
who do the people like what are they
saying in the chat are they giving us
Good Vibes bad vibes but Justin
Jefferson being plus one hunt even
Tyreke oh my God yeah being plus plus
money
I mean I see winners all on that board
uh but Ryan what are the people saying
yeah it's a freebie today Greg but uh
yeah I need your locks so please drop
them in the chat we've got trigger away
saying Aaron Jones and Kenneth Walker TD
uh Zay 23 Justin Jefferson Steve Irwin
saying Dalvin cook uh Aunt guzzy saying
Diggs gonna eat today uh Moody baby digs
hurts at ajc's and Justin Jefferson uh
Tyrone ramandre Stevenson
there's a lot
I see they're they're filling it up but
but let's make a decision bro like who
are we gonna ride with so at this point
in the season I'm big on trust right and
we have to go back to somebody who has
done us well before and the chat seems
to agree Stefan Diggs
I mean Stefan digs against the New York
Jets I feel pretty sauce Gardener is the
man but I feel pretty good about that
how do you guys feel
Stefan Diggs he's been doing it all year
he's been doing it all year got one of
the best quarterbacks I like that one
how about you Sam
I like it the the sauce angle is a bit
scary but digs just get so many looks so
I like it
yeah Diggs Josh Allen I like it I'm
gonna do my magic I'm gonna do my magic
and we're going to boost we're gonna
boost Stefon Diggs from minus 110 to
Plus 125.
poof just like that that's how we do it
here on uh BR betting that's just what
we do we get hooked up by our friends
over there at DraftKings and then we
just make magic happen Sam who do you
you like to get in the end zone today
I'm surprised we didn't see a lot of
this but I'm going with Kelsey he hasn't
scored in a few weeks so he's due just
like Trey Mancini was due for a hit last
night that Greg called uh so we're going
to Travis Kelsey
hey
Scoops right that's all you're looking
for me and Sam always yesterday Scoops
yesterday Scoops today that's what we're
looking for uh make sure you guys tail
us on DraftKings make sure you guys tell
us on DraftKings and uh get rich
together keep dropping your keep
dropping your locks in the chat please
keep dropping your locks in the chat I'm
gonna give out my favorite play today
and I'm gonna uh have my man Ryan pull
it up please pull it up on DraftKings
because uh I saw a bet I saw a bet
um
DeAndre Swift
Aaron Jones 100 plus scrimmage yards for
both now that means rushing and
receiving
rushing and receiving DeAndre Swift
Aaron Jones
I like it nope
there it is there it is plus 330.
talk
DeAndre Swift coming back from injury
looked really good last week Sam you
could talk to me too Aaron Jones he's
that Bale horse he's that Bale cow for
that Packers offense they throw the ball
to him they run the ball my man Swift
can take a screen 85 yard like we got
action here fellas
I like it man I like it
yeah I mean Aaron Jones has done this
Aaron Jones has gotten 100 plus
scrimmage yards three times this season
I mean the man like the the man's
getting the ball left and right
wait so why did you guys take so long to
respond you guys had me just waiting
there for like five seconds because like
you guys made me feel like you guys
weren't rocking well I thought Sam was
gonna jump all over it I thought he was
gonna get super excited and then he
didn't well my you know to take you guys
back behind the curtains my internet
sort of cut out so I was like do I want
to talk and then have it be disconnected
but no I I do like it Greg I I think
those guys are going to be heavily
involved to your point Ryan earlier like
for the Packers this is this is Jones's
offense at this point uh you know Dylan
is has been banished um and Greg I think
you're right I think Swift uh looked
amazing I do think there's gonna be a
lot of points today so I'm with you Greg
a delayed take but I'm with you I will
also say yeah and Swift swift is limited
in the chat's letting us know that today
but all it takes is 199 yard touchdown
run and then a reception and then we're
good that's it and he was limited last
week too right he was limited last year
too right yeah and he
went crazy anyway uh tell me guys what
you think of my pick drop your locks
Ryan talk to the audience what's
happening in the chat
uh yeah I mean like I said there they
want to talk about DeAndre Swift's uh
snap count here but should we uh should
we grade some bets instead because I
don't want I don't wanna I don't want to
talk about his workload that's no thanks
yeah he's still going to get yeah anyway
let's create some bets that's great
because we're gonna give some good vibes
their way okay this is a this is an
interesting Vibe right away uh the
onions good to good to see you back uh
Jamal Williams anytime touchdown
that hit last week it didn't get that
out last week so one of the commenters
gave it out last week and they like had
two and he had like two TDS I believe so
yes you know
that I mean he did just coming right up
gets a touchdown we don't care if Swift
doesn't get a touchdown we just want
yards that's true that was just a funny
way to a funny way to transition there
do you guys do you guys have a grade for
that
what what are the odds the commenters
never give the odds of just stuff I feel
like you're trolling so I'm giving it an
F yeah and I need to show solidarity
with Greg so I will also give it enough
okay
um yeah Jamal Williams odds is uh minus
110 so it's not not great odds there
um but all right let's see
um a lot of people want fantasy football
advice that's that's not what we do here
uh Anthony Pittman Dion Jackson over 20
yards receiving
oh
um
I'll go over I'll sprinkle in some good
friends
I'll go over a c plus
see oh I forgot yeah this is this is
this is a grade not an over under uh
I'll go B minus B minus okay it's gonna
be tough for the for the chat to get
back in the good graces of Greg after
the first one yeah uh trig away Packers
okay this is a good one we don't usually
do this Packers to win by the winning
margin of 1 to 13.
oh
I mean I I would want to see the odds
but
um it is interesting
I mean I feel like
the lines don't typically get blown out
I could I could be wrong saying that I
feel like they usually hang in there
yeah they do uh so you know give it a b
can we ask the commenters when they give
breaks going forward to drop the odds
it's just it's easier for for me to
evaluate with the odds
I feel like exactly
I feel like that's because that might be
like minus 400 and then it's like I'm
probably not taking that yeah you know
yeah
Greg
I gave it a b a b all right B uh
all right we've got uh Rob Dog Tyreek
Hill two plus TDS the odds there he
didn't drop the odds of course he didn't
drop the odds I'm giving you the odds
Plus 550.
well I mean
there's not many more players that are
fun to bet more fun to bet on than
Tyreek Hill
um and he's just getting a ton of looks
but I I don't I know he's getting a just
an absolute mass amount of yards but it
does feel like waddle is stealing a lot
of the touchdowns
um so you know plus 550 worth of spring
goal sprinkle but I can't say it's a
lock
Greg it's a b b plus all right
let's move on okay Davis Jake uh Packers
minus three and a half
it's a lot of a lot of Packers talk yeah
um
the Packers Packers minus three and a
half
yeah
I I get that's probably where I would
lean I would lean on this being a decent
spot for the Packers potentially bounce
back
um that Lions defense is just so bad
it's just so bad
um but I don't know I I it's hard for me
to trust the Packers at all right now I
I would lean that way but I don't have
the confidence and then where I'm
willing to put my money on them right
now
d d
you're yeah yeah the the chat the chat
is gone yeah I'm not I'm not feeling the
chat today no you're not bringing love
no they brought bad fights we bring Good
Vibes
you're not not today not today okay so
it's a long night sometimes yeah long
night a lot of celebrations more
celebrations tonight tomorrow
so you know personally I'm in a good
vibe but the chat not feeling it today
uh
so yeah okay
we'll do uh last one here uh charbel
Bobby Raheem moster anytime TD plus 110
on draft absolutely love that that's an
a whoever that is send them a t-shirt
send them a hoodie that is an a I like
that now you're bringing up yeah
complete Vibes that's a that's a d and
you know what Tyree kills scoring zero
TDS the Bears are gonna shut them out
today and when 35 nothing Justin Bieber
five touchdowns
Greg went back to being sincere so now
I'm truly you had to even it out I love
it I love it got it even and out Ryan
let's get up let's get on up out of here
bro I think that's enough
hey thank you guys for tapping in
hopefully you guys win today follow
Sam's picks because he been going crazy
this whole year uh
for producer Ryan Sam Richmond my name
is Greg Ivory we
or out of here peace
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]